gimp ce qu'on appelle du maître gims
annonce qu'il va donc justement avec
cette grande chanteuse donc vraiment on
va on va cesser c'est le choc des
cultures qu'il va faire un featuring
avec valérie pécresse vraie ou fausse
bague à la mayenne et vas-y info bah
franchement copains ming oui c'est oui
mais je n'ai jamais entendu parler de
valérie pécresse a dans la bouche de
gims quoi bon ça on il tend à casser une
info à peut-être et bien effectivement
en fait c'est faux seins puisque valérie
pécresse qui est donc pour ceux qui nous
rejoignent peut-être la famille de
magali c'est la présidente de la région
ile de france qui s'associe au chanteur
peu un contrat politique voilà normal
que pose la question que j'arrête je
pense qu en kabyle de cole comme un tube
de colle et voit combien de fils de
colle le pense pas car midi pendant
quatre villes mais devant moi combien at
il affirmé
ses rangs quelques mots et de rien c'est
au pont de tancarville mais chassez mais
qu'est-ce que vous m'emmerdez avec ça
mais alors les amis
donc effectivement on va essayer de
revenir cette émission je voulais vous
annoncer donc c'est le projet de gims
annoncé le marathon des talents
génération gims avec la région ile de
france en partenariat
vous choisissez une de mes chansons vous
l'a chantée en piano voix guitare voix
et le gagnant sera sélectionné pour
participer à un très gros événement pour
faire la première partie de cette
alliance qui est vrai c'est que guînes
sur ce moment avec les sétois qui
l'avait annoncée pour le coup les douze
salopards qui va être un événement un
petit peu comme comme les [ __ ] enfin
la parallèle pour récupérer de l'argent
et maintenant cette initiative avec
valérie pécresse est ce que vous trouvez
que gym c'est plutôt bien ce qui fait il
en train de s'appliquer à fruits auprès
des jeunes auprès des causes on
l'appelle à peu le nouveau goldman et
c'est machine à tubes est ce que c'est
je trouvais ça formidable parce qu'il
est passé d' idole pour les jeunes ados
à sare familiale voix sans jamais
changer ce qui faisait finalement en
fait il a réussi à faire ce que aya
nakamura n'a pas encore réussi mais
qu'il ya je pense vie d'être beaucoup
plus transversales comme une énergie la
wii fit mais non mr gibbs est en train
de perdre son fils en train de donner
aux autres de les rappeurs on peut
discuter parfois ça c'est un cliché
ça fait un cliché mais en revanche que
j'aime bien chez game c'est que oui il
aurait pété un plomb il a beaucoup
d'argent et des chrétiens il est jamais
dans des mauvaises histoires dans la
presse et tout ça je il est en train de
prouver que c'est quelqu'un de bien si
le temps doit le prouver en tant que
chef le connaissant en privé honnêtement
c'est qu'un cac est d'une humilité
incroyable c'est à dire qu'il est il a
rien de deux stars de ce que tu as fait
ce que guillaume ça marche lors la
presse dans la presse people et tout ça
c'était tu l'as déjà paparazzé est ce
qu'elle est
parce qu'on ne le voit jamais non ça
marche ça c'est facile avec quelqu'un
parce quelqu'un oui vive la colère six
mois c'est comme d'hab
franchement
on m'embête il a une vie trop classique
voilà je vais croiser dans une boîte à
marrakech il s'amusait bien il a
certainement rien type c'est que le
juridique est en train de décéder rien
dit alors le juridique mais sans doute
sujet alors les amis oui tu veux dire
quelque chose dans ce café par la passe
mais à tous parce que justement il a
indi classique vous avez rien à dire
sauf que marrakech je te dis pas qui
c'est